I talk about the volume of pain.
There are times
when it's so intense,
when the volume is so high,
that I just wish
somebody would come along
and unzip my body
and just take it away.
Humankind has constantly tried
to define pain.
It isn't easy.
- Most of the pains
that we feel are day-to-day.
And they do resolve.
They're part
of our body's protection -
making us rest and protect the area
and make sure it doesn't get
infected if it's a wound.
And so day-to-day pain
may be kind of annoying,
but it is really important.
A life without pain would be
very dangerous and life-threatening.
- So if I were to tell you
how my pain is at the moment,
it actually feels today
as if someone has tried
to put a wetsuit on me.
But this wetsuit is just covered
in tiny tacks
that are really, really sharp.
And they're pulling
on this wetsuit all the time.
It also feels
as if there are people with drills
on the soles of my feet,
and there are lots and lots
and lots of people,
and they're just drilling
into my feet.
And my legs feel really tight,
as if someone's got giant hands
that are just really,
really squeezing.
- So neuropathic pain
is really intense.
It's experienced
as almost real events,
like being pinched and squeezed,
very severe,
what feel like electrical pulses.
And clinical experts in pain
are able to right away identify
neuropathic pain
because of these awful descriptors.
The last kind of pain,
the third kind of pain,
is really the mystery.
And that is the existence of pain
for which
there is no obvious origin.
So that does not in any way mean
that it isn't real.
It's 100% real.
It's just that our understanding
of our bodies is limited
at the moment,
and you can't find an injury.
So, we're left with a population
of people who are really suffering
from pain,
and it interferes with their life,
but we don't understand
where it comes from.
- Pain itself
is a hidden disability.
And I think it's really difficult
to get that across,
because you can't see
somebody else's pain.
I suppose in every walk of life,
if you feel understood,
that's half the battle.
And I think that journey
of trying to explain yourself
is a really hard one.
It's absolutely exhausting.
When you don't feel believed,
it has such a massive effect
on your mental wellbeing
that living with that pressure,
it's almost just as hard
as the pain.
And, well,
why should people understand
if they haven't experienced it?
But also
there is the word compassion,
and you're hoping that there might
be more compassion around.
- I think the outstanding mystery
is why is it
that a substantial number
of our population
are suffering from pain without
any obvious biological purpose?
- I'm not sure that in my lifetime
there's going to be a magic potion
that suddenly will take
all the pain away.
But I think the more
that we all talk about it,
that's where I feel hopeful.
That's where
I can do my little bit.
That's the optimistic bit.
As for where all the nails
and the screwdrivers
and the drills in my feet will go,
I don't know.
But I have to believe
that I will find my way forward.